[Musique]
c'est donc ça que j'ai inventé des
devoirs vous avez deviné ce que c'était
apparemment c'est une éolienne d'un
genre nouveau en effet puisque on s'est
arrangé pour cacher le principe même de
l'éolien donc imaginer que dans chaque
petite feuille vous avez vu il ya un
générateur entre les rotations par le
vent les feuilles tourner sur leur axe
et produisent de l'énergie
c'est une idée très simple et vous vous
donnez un peu une représentation de ce
que ça produit c'est à peu près
l'équivalent des 80% de besoins
électriques d'une famille assez grand ça
fait 9 mètres de haut ça peut alimenter
une quinzaine de réverbères à led ou
encore l'équivalent de 16 mille cinq
cents kilomètres de recharge de voitures
électriques
donc c'est quand même une petite
centrale et on vous dira électrique
toussaint caché dans une forme organique
et l'idée bandits venus je m'en souviens
très bien c'était en 2011
c'est après les événements de fukushima
souvenez-vous le tsunami les images qui
passent en boucle tout le monde
bouleversé
moi même je peux pas rester insensible
et je me dis il faut arrêter avec ces
méga centrale qui concentre des moyens
de production peut-être que la solution
ce serait d'imaginer des petites
productions locales décentralisées à
l'échelle d'une famille justement de
l'entreprise et comme ça je me convaincs
qu'il faut trouver une solution de
proximité à taille humaine
à l'époque je ne suis pas ingénieur je
suis romancier
j'écris des histoires pour la télévision
je suis très loin de l'univers
scientifique et c'est cette raison là
qui m'a donné l'ouverture de l'idée
puisque quand on n'est pas conditionnée
par un dogme on a un esprit libre et
ainsi j'ai pu avoir cette audace parce
que c'en est une qui va à l'encontre du
dogme éolien qui jurent que par la
monoturbine 100 m 2 aux grosses et
possiblement le dangereuses ou en tout
cas pour les oiseaux voilà pertes en
ligne enfin plein de phénomènes
secondaire et donc oser penser la pelure
ailier de turbines de miser sur les
petits vents al'inverse des vents
laminaire miser sur la turbulence
c'était tout à fait une audace qu'un
scientifique bien conditionner n'aurait
pas pu produire si ta première avantage
enfin en même temps c'est une limite
qu'est ce que je il faut que l'idée est
là ça va être quoi le principe de
génération de courant étant pas
ingénieur je me convaincs qu'il faut que
ce soit très simple et costaud simple
pour que je puisse le comprend et
costauds parce que ayant fait pas mal de
voile je sais que le vent peut être très
destructeur et je sais pas j'ai
l'intuition de la dynamo je connais rien
l'univers mécanique jeu par la moindre
idée de ce qu'est une dynamo mais je
sais que sur le vélo
mon vieux vélos fond du garage la dynamo
est toujours l'un alors que le vélo est
quoi le nom pourri donc je prends ma
dynamo je la casse avec un marteau parce
que là ya pas de vie sont pas ouvrir et
un coup de marteau j'arrive à voir qu'en
fait il rien d'autre qu'un aimant qui
tourne dans un bobinage de cuivre très
simple meirieu de simplicité et la
dynamo c'est une molette qui tourne sur
une jante et qui fait allumer la petite
loupiote c'est une idée si simple
khaled inspirante et donc je pars avec
cette intuition là et
figurez vous qu après cinq ans de r&d
sur nantes génératrice forte de
plusieurs brevets qui en barrent certes
beaucoup de d'électronique de puissance
de régulation des microprocesseurs il ya
beaucoup de gêne électriques eurent
marqué c'est malgré tout le même
principe qui prévaut à nîmes enquêteurs
dans un bobinage de cuir
comme quoi il faut croire dans ses
intuitions je reste toujours et qu'on
problème parce que je maintenant je vais
où je sais pas comment faire et par
chance je viens d'une famille qui compte
pas mal d'ingénieurs certains fameux
dans mon oncle henric est connu pour
avoir conçu le programme du concorde
c'est un crack en turbulence
c'est l'autre héros d'enfance on a vu
naître l'avion parce que nous en parle
et on a vu le dessin de la le delta on a
vu le nez qui se se pencher produits
comme ça il avait inventé le
biomimétisme avant l'heure donc
peut-être que c'est une source
d'inspiration où j'ai biberonné de la
science comme ça sans le savoir
mais c'est à lui je pense d hiver qui je
me tourne pour valider les premiers
calculs que j'avais fait à partir de
deux connaissances cliquez sur internet
et en radio sur l'autorité fait tomber
la sentence pas content on truque je
pourrais peut-être marcher mais enfin
j'imagine que si tu arrives à sortir en
boîte par feuille vu leur taille
on peut penser que on n'aura pas plus
d'arbres est parfait pour un objectif de
3000 3500 watts c'est un minimum
il te faudrait travailler de 500
feuilles ça va être ingérable
le rat des cas partout des connectiques
il ya 3500 aérogénérateurs il n'y a pas
de modèle économique possible
n'empêche pour moi il avait dit c'est
pas con ton truc cette démarche il
avalait une validation et donc de la
partie en train de bricoler un proto à
partir d'un petit moteur que je trouve
sur l'une commerce prend celui du moteur
d'imprimantes que je verse en générateur
g6 il ya une boue de gouttière jeu pour
faire 2-2 pas le contrarier
et je vais sur mon balcon je t embrasse
je recueille 1 watt exactement ce
qu'avait dit henri partir de là il ya
des attitudes soit on se dit peut-être
sympa mais comme dit envie c'est
ingérable donc laisse tomber passe à
autre chose
ou alors on se retrousse les manches et
de marc bret ont fait de watts
il est de 2 on passe à droite passé le
chemin que j'ai pris et
évidemment ça ne fait pas tout seul ni
en ce jour nono premier proto
industriels ont on arrive ici affaire
neuf fois tu as un saut enfin 9 watts un
jour très très loin du coup il faut
beaucoup plus d'ici de ts on passe à 35
watts des mois et des mois de travail
on passe à 65 des jours en améliore le
modèle mais on n'y est pas encore là le
temps passe il faut se convaincre qu'il
faut continuer pour atteindre cet
objectif de modèle économique
et on peut penser que j'avais mis sur
mon bureau une devise un peu pour
traduire le mouvement je vous la donne
essayez encore raté encore raté mieux et
c'est ce que nous faisions une phrase de
samuel beckett comme quoi je restais un
littéraire et à force de travail
d'itérations de proto en pro tour on
arrive à produire 100 watts par feuille
donc ainsi en divisant par 100 le nombre
de générateurs on arrive au modèle
économique et tout ça donc ce fait en
trouvant de l'argent j'ai sauté une
étape mais c'est pas grave je le redis
maintenant c'est que avant d'arriver à
600 watts il a fallu que je m'entoure de
talent donc j'ai recruté des ingénieurs
avec un premier investissement fait en
partie par les fonds propres et en
partie avec un investisseur que j'ai
convaincu de mettre cent mille euros
rien que sur le potentiel de l'idi ça va
être les premières argent que j'ai pu
recruter les tout premiers ingénieurs
est arrivé au chemin qui viendra conter
des prototypes qui ont conduit à son
grade parfait mais
premier montera de la start up quand on
a créé si cette opiniâtreté qu'il faut
mettre tous les jours tous les jours au
delà des 100 mille euros de départ c'est
ce misé sur l'intelligence collective
conserver les talents pour pas qu'il
parte ailleurs cette année certes la
gran torino 20 et enfin s'armer de
patience mais bien sûr essangui le rouge
s'épuisent rapidement faut donc aussi
savoir financer le parcours qui dure 4 5
ans quand on est dans l'innovation
industrielle que c'était notre cas et
alors là on n'y a pas de secret soit
vous avez de l'argent de famille soit
vous faites appel aux investisseurs de
type capital risque ou business angels
c'est ou alors encore un peu de
crowdfunding le financement participatif
qui marche très bien maintenant dans
capital aussi et moi j'ai fait un mix
des deux j'ai levé on peu près quatre
ans 3 millions d'euros dont 2 millions
4,1 capitale avec cet argent on a pu
faire tout un parcours qui a conduit à
déposer une quinzaine d' inventions et à
multiplier les prototypes dont une
présérie nous avons planté en fin 2015
début 2016 une présérie en france en
suisse en allemagne dizaines d'arbres
dont les deux que vous avez vus à la cap
21 qui ont été vus par les 195 nation là
il a passé un événement avec un colossal
aller à l'échelle du monde puisque on a
reçu plein de commandes tout le monde
comprenait tout le monde a adhéré il
c'était le moment d'y aller quoi passer
à la vitesse supérieure si le time to
market qui vous impose de sortir de
produits dont les des rivières maturité
c'était bon et donc je recrute des
commerciaux une supply chain pour
l'industrialisation
on a conduit les bureaux je lance les
offres commerciales se regardent des
fournisseurs et on fabrique on commence
et en parallèle de sa pour financer je
lève en tout cas j'ai engagé une
augmentation de capital objectif 5
millions dé les trois mois normalement
il faut six mois après
avi - pour lever des fonds de cette
importance et là on est tellement en
confiance que porté par l'enthousiasmé
général
on se dit on va y arriver et en plus
j'ai dans mon équipe un ancien ministre
l'économie qui nous a rejoint en capital
dont je dis aucun problème on va les
trouver les 5 millions par ce mouvement
décrit bien la force des start up et en
montant leur vulnérabilité
c'est qu'on est sûr de mélange de
d'inconscience et surtout le soir
certains diraient de mégalomanie qui
crée cette dynamique positive mais en
même temps une sorte de force aveugle
qui vous empêche de percevoir toutes les
difficultés qui pointe dans la touche
d'humour ou d'entendre des signaux
faibles pour ce qu'il a été notre cas
les signaux faibles c'est la
persévérance du temps vous figurer les
cent mille euros de départ avait permis
de faire un an avec 4 5 ingénieur les
mêmes cent mille euros
on faisait un mois donc avant cela va
très très vite que l'argent par très
très vite
y'en a pas de chiffre d'affaires donc
faut financer par l'extérieur et quand
l'argent n'arrive pas c'est l'accident
c'est sous un inconnu vous direz mais
comment se fait-il
avec toutes ces bonnes auspices ce
carnet de commandes plein comment ça
peut arriver ça ça arrive avec la 66
mille sociétés en france par an à qui ça
arrive donc je suis j'ai pas échappé à
la reine je m'en veux pour avoir manqué
de vigilance
et ce profite de l'occasion pour
rappeler quelques uns le premier c'est
bien sûr de veiller à
à gérer ce temps c'est plus dur surtout
quand à la fin le vos propres soutiens
vos actionnaires aux salariés commencent
à douter de vous les qualités de
d'innovateur qu'on louait au départ tout
d'un coup vous sont reprochés comme
peut-être responsable des difficultés et
enfin ce temps c'est tous les jours
convaincre des investisseurs tous les
jours rassurés les équipes et en même
temps des poussées par les fonds
d'investissement qu'on rencontre pour
signer des offres commerciales pour
montrer que le marché plus profond que
la simple apparence ou l'excitation que
par exemple la cap 21 a suscité et avoir
un marché profond c'est quoi passer
signé des offres commerciales avec
l'amérique l'australie le japon
c'est ce qu'on fait est donc un moment
on a dépensé
enfin il faut tellement d'argent pour
fabriquer tout ce qu'on vend quand on
est en situation limite frauduleuse en
la loi des commerces le dit vendre est
quelque chose qu'on n'est pas capable de
faire avec et c'est un délit c'est une
escroquerie donc j'ai pris le chemin de
la protection du tribunal qui a ouvert
une période d'observation de six mois
avec un marché de dupes parce que
pendant cette période on n'a pas le
droit de faire de 1 euro de dette et
nous la tête est arrivé avec la relance
urssaf et ça a été le truc liquidation
et la du jour au lendemain
voulait plus rien tout ce que vous avez
créées en cinq ans toute cette énergie
positive cette valeur ses brevets tout
ça c'est fini le bureau le soir mais
vous devez dégager tous les contrats
s'arrête c'est assez violent
on dit d'ailleurs que beaucoup de
suicides divorce ou dépression suivent
les liquidations
rassurez vous je dis ça à ma femme qui
dans la salle
rappaz de 10h30 de dépression parce
qu'en fait on est porté par quelque
chose de plus puissant et qui je pense
qu'il ya à voir avec l'origine de l'idée
puis elle est inspirée du vivant une
observation la nature tout ce qui est né
du vivant poussé erronée pour peu que le
terreau soit bon je pense le terreau
l'arbre avant est très bon on l'a
démontré plein de fois et c'est une
solution qui est attendu partout dans le
monde donc ya pas de doute qu'on va
surmonter cet épisode et que les
attentes formulaires des milliers de
gens qui ont fait confiance à cette
solution qui l'attendent qui préfèrent
même leur jardin pour mettre un arbre je
lui dis se ferait pas
[Applaudissements]